When I,
when I talked to friends or family and I tell them,
what if we don't stop behaving this way,
it would be you don't stop lying.
If you don't become more too thrilled about what's happening,
then this could end in,
in,
in genocide and they just look like,
why are you talking about
you?
I'd always does that.
I mean that's true.
There's not even a shock.
Yeah,
I know.
It shouldn't even be a shark because it's the natural state of affairs that
always happens.
You know,
we,
we also think that there was something that was in some sense limited to,
well let's say what happened in Germany in the 20th century,
but it's not limited to that at all.
It happens everywhere.
Berlin,
where I live,
it's full of monuments from the Holocaust museums with,
with,
Oh
I know,
never forget.
Still it's,
it's,
it's not something that we have internalized somehow that,
okay,
then you can read,
you can remember what you don't understand.
Great.
No matter how hard you try and the issue is,
what does it mean to remember?
But what I know what it means to remember,
like technically if you make a mistake and you've represented it properly in
your memory,
you don't make the same mistake again.
That's actually what memories for,
right?
Because you think,
well,
why do you remember the past?
Well there's two reasons.
One is to repeat things you did well that worked out and to not repeat things
you did badly.
The purpose of memory is to do that.
It's not to represent the world.
I mean it is,
but only institute works works basically and to not do what doesn't work.
Yeah,
exactly.
He used to bring the success as into the future and leave the failures behind
you say,
well we're going to remember the Holocaust.
Okay,
well what are you going to remember?
So humans cannot have like a collective memory that they used to like a warning
signal.
Oh sure.
We do that too.
But we have formulated properly.
You know,
so,
so one question while a question and this question has plagued me forever,
I would say is,
well,
what is it that we're supposed to have learned from what happened in Germany in
the 1930s?
What are we learn that there was something wrong with Germans?
Is that the lesson?
That's not really a very useful lesson.
Um,
that,
that was isolated to that time and place that,
that it was the consequence of following pathological leadership.
That it was a consequence of economic turmoil.
And there's all sorts of things you could learn from it.
My sense is that what needs to be learned from it is that that's what we're
like.
So it's not this sub culture is a country,
it's not the German and the Dutch sheets,
chimpanzees do it.
This is the great discovery of Jane Goodall,
right?
She found that the chimps raided,
you know,
and,
and when they were juveniles in particular,
and when they,
when they're out on the borders of their territory doing their patrols.
Yeah.
And they came across chimps from another troop,
they tear them to pieces.
It's like,
well,
okay,
that's not human.
That's,
this is deeper than,
it's even deeper than human.
This wasn't,
she rolls up we into desk.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
She was shocked.
Well,
for a bunch of reasons.
I mean,
first of all,
she was properly cautious because she thought that human interactions with the
chimpanzees might have interfered with their natural behavior.
And that was such a shocking finding.
She was unwilling to publish it.
But I also think it violated her noble savage assumption.
You know,
that the state of nature was basically good.
And I mean,
lots of people think the reason that human beings are corrupt because they're
socialized to be corrupt.
You know,
that the reason we're war,
like for example,
is because we're socialized improperly.
And I mean you can certainly socialize people to be more or less warlike,
but this is a way deeper problem.
Then mirror socialization,
you know,
even though socialization is very,
very important.
So she,
yeah,
she was very hesitant to publish it,
but she did.
And it's been,
it's become clear in the,
in the decades following that that was normative behavior for chimpanzees.
So,
but it's also partly the fact that people have,
we have ourselves backwards.
We always ask stupid questions.
Like,
why are we anxious?
That's a stupid question.
The question,
the real question is how is it ever that anyone has ever calm even for a
microsecond?
Right?
And it's the case.
Why are we aggressive?
It's like,
no,
how is it that we can now and then be peaceful?
That's the question.
So we have these things backwards.
We don't understand ourselves and we can't remember what we don't understand.
Yeah,
you can remember what you don't understand.
It's uh,
it's a,
in some sense to try to remember what you do and understand is to be in a state
of trauma.
And I would say that that would characterize the Germans.
Hitler was,
um,
a singular personality in very creative,
very assertive,
um,
and also very good at
pattern recognition.
It was part of his creativity.
Okay.
So now here's the,
Oh yes,
he was a very creative person.
Oh yes.
Well,
it's part of being creative is to recognize patterns.
To pick them up unconsciously because that's what an artist does,
is pick up patterns unconsciously and then portray them right.
And in an attempt to make them conscious that that's part of the artistic
process.
Okay.
So now he's brutalized,
right?
He went through trench warfare and World War One and he's thought it because he
wanted to become an artist and,
and he applied to become an artist.
I think it was in,
I think it was in Vienna.
Yeah,
I think it was three times.
And he was,
Hebrews rejected all three times.
Homeless.
Many of his friends had been killed in world war one was brutal.
And there's no evidence that he was a coward in World War One.
He got a medal for valor,
you know,
and if I remember correctly,
there was one time in his life where he was in trench warfare,
is seen with his friends and he wandered off away from them.
And when he came back,
a mortar had landed in the middle of the group and killed everyone.
Now that does something to you psychologically as well,
right?
Because it makes you feel special,
marked out because you didn't die.
But everyone else did.
Right.
So anyways,
so there is Hitler and then he's surrounded by brutalized man in Germany is
completely demolished and,
and,
and the economy is in shambles in the communists or threatening and it's like,
and then,
and then of course there's hyperinflation and,
and,
and the Germans all feel betrayed and it's like it's a mass,
a mass,
the magnitude of which we can barely even imagine.
And so then he starts talking to people cause he's not very happy and,
and he's willing to go with the crowd leads him.
That's the thing.
Now the funny thing is,
is that a good leader has a dialogue with the crowd,
but a good leader isn't willing to go wherever the crowd wants to go.
It's a dialogue and not Hitler.
It's not a dialogue precisely.
Or if it is,
it's a dialogue with a darker side of it.
So this is,
this is what happened.
So he stands up in front of the crowd and he has some oratorical ability so we
can captivate people.
And because maybe he is one of those vessels through which the crowd can speak.
So he says these sentences,
nothing happens.
And he says these sentences and he gets a bit of rise out of the crowd.
And then he says the same sentences,
but he puts a flourish on them and then it gets a real rise out of the crowd.
And the little pattern recognition module in his mind thinks,
okay,
not so much of that and quite a bit more of this.
And so then he does that again and he gets a little better at it.
And so there's quite a bit more of the crowd pleasing rhetoric and the crowds
get more enthusiastic and he's watching and attending and shifting his behavior
pattern.
The pattern,
the pattern is met,
the pattern of the crowds desire is manifesting itself in his imagination and
he's giving voice to it.
The question is,
well,
what does the angry post war German crowd want?
So you could think of Hitler as the articulated embodiment of the maddened
crowd,
right?
And then there's a dynamic,
So the crowd boot broadcasts,
it's resentment to the leader,
and the leader says,
oh,
this is what you mean in the crowd goes,
yes,
that's what we mean.
And then they get more fired up and,
and,
and the leader listens and recognizes the pattern,
says,
so this is what you want?
And the crowd goes yes.
And feedback loop.
Right then he was very good at that.
He was,
you willing to use the gift of his voice in the service of the darkest desire of
the maddened crowd.
While it's like calling Satan himself up from the depths to good enough
metaphor,
men,
unless someone can come up with a better one,
like that's a good one.